[Music]
so good afternoon everyone and welcome
to this session my name is Mira Hashem
I'm the global product product
management lead for Chrome OS ecosystem
products which is devices as well as
Android applications so I'm going to be
you know so to get today me along with
my colleague Shah here then we will be
talking to you about Android apps for
Chromebooks so before I get started um
wanted to understand a little bit more
about you so how many people are
familiar with the chrome operating
system is everyone and how many of you I
see some Chromebooks in the room on I
see some people using them but how many
of you have used a Chromebook yourself
okay great and then and then how many
how many people here are actually
decision makers for their businesses in
terms of what would be deployed app
developers do we have any app developers
over here okay okay yeah so it's a mix
and we will be going over a variety of
topics with you and and you know so it's
and we would love to take any questions
in the end so so we should go with this
pretty fast because most of the audience
seems familiar with the chrome operating
system but as you know Chrome OS is
Google's productivity operating system
it's designed for the large screens and
it's designed with a few guiding
principles in mind so first of this is
speed so if you have used Chromebooks
you know that they boot up in 8 to 10
seconds so they're really fast and that
was a fundamental design consideration
for the team right from the beginning
the other part about Chromebooks is
they're very very simple so if you get a
new Chromebook you are up and running on
it if you have never used a Chromebook
before literally in a few minutes so
very easy to use for users but also very
very easy for administrators to
administrate so and I think probably a
lot of people know that you know that as
well in terms of security security is
built into Chrome books at every layer
so starting from the hardware to the
operating system to the application
layer all the applications are sandboxed
which means that for your chrome devices
you can think of it as anti viruses
automatically built-in you never have to
worry about security patches and
downloads and things like that and last
is that shareability is inherent to the
design of Chromebooks so you can
literally grab any Chromebook and it's
yours as soon as you sign in with within
a few seconds and that's a feature which
schools love you know so students can
grab any Chromebooks and use them and
increasingly businesses as well so the
users have actually responded really
well to these design principles and what
we are seeing is that in United States
in United States every school day
30,000 Chromebooks are activated every
day if you look at the aggregate data
58% of devices sold in US schools last
year for Chromebooks so it's more
Chromebooks than all of the devices
combined and Chromebooks adoption is
also growing in international markets so
future source recently announced just a
few days ago that Chromebooks were also
the best selling devices in Sweden so
Chrome has been doing very well in
education but beyond education and this
is I think mainly a business audience we
are also seeing increase in popularity
of Chromebooks so in retail which is
consumers buying Chromebooks from Best
Buy Amazon there was a 20% growth last
year in United States and this is in a
declining market so chrome continues to
be the bright spot which is growing in
businesses according to IDC 800,000
Chromebooks were were bought by
businesses last year and thanks to all
the thanks to our users and the adoption
which we are seeing Chrome OS was the
second most popular productive
the operating system in United States
for all of 2016 and another interesting
data point which we which IDC informed
us about there and a future scape survey
and it said by 2018 25% of Fortune 500
companies are going to have some form of
IT supported chrome devices in their
organization so in case you are
wondering what are the what are the
organizations these are some some of the
organizations who are using Chromebooks
or chrome devices who have given us
permission to use their names and share
them with you so you can see they span a
whole range and I don't know if anyone
is seeing their own company on this one
but you know but you can see they range
from retailers to healthcare to
financial services so it's it's so it's
a very good mix of businesses that are
using chrome devices at this point so
let's let's switch let's switch gears a
little bit and let's talk a little bit
more about chrome devices at work and
how our business is using these devices
so we are actually seeing a lot of usage
of chrome devices by businesses to
expand the use of computing so we are
seeing them use chrome devices to take
computing where they didn't have
computing before so an example of it is
we are seeing businesses use devices
therefore their employees are using it
every day and often times they're using
it in a shared setting so this is the
some of the places where we are seeing
this is in retail backrooms
you sing it on manufacturing floors we
are seeing in assisted living centers we
are seeing it in libraries we are seeing
it in government facilities so if you
think about it this use case actually is
kind of analogous to two schools where
businesses want to get computing to more
employees they can share the device it's
very shareable it's very simple it's
very easy for IT administrators to
manage so another area where we are
beginning to see a lot of chrome usage
is digital science
and kiosks so kiosks an example of that
would be you go to a you go to a hotel
lobby and you want to check in right so
that is using running a single
application or an example could also be
a public session where again if you
think about a hotel they want to have a
device where any any any guests can go
and use it and they can use it for
browsing for you know they can do some
web-based email so it's a shared device
for the guests to use the other one is
digital science so in digital science
again we are seeing different types of
usage so if you look at digital science
we are seeing for example restaurant
chains use it to show their menus you
know so it's using a single application
and you can order from these and because
these devices are so easy to manage and
you can do all of the management
remotely it's very cost effective for
businesses to do this another example
which we are seeing is is retailers
using promotional video so at your
retail sales point you are running
promotional video and again you can push
that remotely you can manage it you can
pick these devices to see how they are
doing so we are beginning to see a lot
of different usage and with Android
applications coming to these chrome
devices the number of uses which you can
get from them is increasing so you can
start getting your favorite Android
applications on these devices and will
be we will be showing you some examples
of those devices of those applications
ahead we'll be doing that but in
addition to that another thing which we
are seeing is that a lot of businesses
actually develop custom Android
applications already so and currently
they can use those applications either
on the phones or on the tablets and some
of the example applications it could be
an employee scheduling application it
could be an inventory management
application it could be a charting
application for patients so now what we
are seeing is we are seeing these
businesses start to test these
applications on their Chromebooks so now
from there from a usage point of view
they have the same application running
all the way from their phones to tablets
to laptops so it provides a very
consistent experience for their users
and their employees
so Chrome comes in multiple form factors
so chrome devices come in multiple form
factors we have the Chromebooks which
are the laptops we have chrome boxes
which are the mini desktops chrome base
which is the all-in-one and also the
chrome bit which is a small stick which
you can attach to your monitor to create
a digital sign very cost-effectively so
depending on your application you can
choose the right form factor which is
best for your business and all of these
devices can be managed from the same
Chrome device management console and
here is a sampling of some of the
devices we have in market today so this
is this is a sampling this is not all of
the devices so as you can see and I you
know as you can see almost all global
OMS are building chrome devices whether
it's a SUSE Lenovo a sir
HP a open Samsung so there's a variety
of OMS we are building these devices and
bringing them to market so you have a
choice of OMS the other thing if you
want you know if you're not familiar
with it
there is a whole range of form factors
so not only do you have clam shells you
also have reversible or convertible
devices you also have signage devices
which is the a open chrome box mini or
the a open chrome base which you know
you have the asus chromebit which is the
stick itself and last year we also
launched several devices specifically
from work so we have the HP Chromebook
13 we have the lenovo lenovo thinkpad 13
this is a Chromebook 14 so there's a
whole range of devices so chrome has a
very it is various there is a lot of
variety to choose from
depending on your application and use
case
I mentioned the chrome management
console before but it comes with a with
a lot of different app math it comes
with full management capabilities and
and you know and on the devices also I
should have said it if you look at a
device portfolio we are continually
expanding the device portfolio so we
have evolved the device portfolio
recently to add devices which are
optimized for Android applications so
same for the chrome management console
the chrome management console is also
keeps evolving to add new functionality
and some of the new functionality which
we have added is the ability to manage
Android applications for your chrome
devices from the same management console
so if you have legacy infrastructure and
this is a lot of the work which team has
done over the last year year and a half
then that legacy infrastructure works
very well with chrome devices if you
have you can get app compatibility you
obviously have the web applications
Android applications are coming but we
have a variety of virtualization
providers Citrix VMware Amazon
workspaces identity so in terms of
identity single sign-on is is supported
and again from a variety of providers so
octa is one of them being is another one
peripherals we are we added support for
us BC docking last year and in terms of
printers you can support printing in two
different ways either the Cloud Print or
through H there is a chrome app through
which you can HP chrome app through
which 100 million plus HP printers can
be can be used along with your chrome
devices and then in terms of
connectivity we also provide a variety
of providers using which businesses can
connect securely and some of the
examples of those Apollo ultra networks
and Dell SonicWALL
so if you have legacy infrastructure and
you want to deploy Chromebooks in that
context please contact us and we are
happy to work with you on that
so before we talked about Android apps
we wanted to give you context on Chrome
overall and we also wanted to talk about
Chrome devices for work for the rest of
this discussion we are going to be
focusing on Android apps for Chromebooks
so we are going to talk about a few
things first we are going to talk about
a design approaches and what kind of
design choices did we make so that it is
it so that it'll be a consistent and
good experience which adds to the
strengths of the products so users get
the best possible experience so we will
talk about some of the devices which
have been built recently which are
optimized or which are designed with the
Play Store in mind with the Google Play
Store in mind and then we are going to
be showing some app examples we are
going to be doing a demo show you some
sample apps and then we are going to end
with tips for optimizing your Android
apps on Chromebooks so that's a
run-through of what we will be talking
about so let's talk a little bit about
the design choices which we made so
Chrome OS is Google's productivity
operating system because it's the
productivity operating system users want
to be able to multitask they want to be
able to use multiple windows they want
to be able to resize their windows one
of the things which I think uses that
users really love about Chromebooks is
it comes with a Chrome browser the
desktop Chrome browser with with support
for full extensions tabs productivity so
the Chrome browser is there so you can
still use all of your web applications
but the way we have brought the Android
applications to Chromebooks is you still
get multiple windows with your Android
applications so you could be running
different Android applications in
different windows you can resize the
Android application depending on the
capability of the application so from a
user so the design itself is is focused
on ensuring that users can be productive
and they can do multitasking on these
large screens if manageability I think
we have already touched on that we make
sure that manageability was included
it's a very so the simplicity continues
for administrators then if you look at
the if you think about Google Play and
if you think about the billions of users
who are using Android applications and
Android phones today we also wanted to
make sure that
had a consistent experience when they
started using these Android when they
started using the Android applications
on the chrome devices so Android
applications are touch optimized but
Chromebooks have different capabilities
in addition to some of them have
touchscreens some of them don't but they
have capabilities like you have the
trackpad so that so just as you know you
would use your finger I mean now you
have a precision touch trackpad so you
can use your trackpad in order to
navigate the touch elements on these
applications and you can click on them
so for a user who's used to doing that
on its phone when they come over here
it's a very natural motion for them to
start using the trackpad they you know
of course they get their familiar
applications the other thing is if you
look at the Android applications most
Android applications are designed with
offline in mind so when I am when I'm on
an airplane and I'm using my my Android
phone I mean obviously I use the Google
Nexus or Google pixel phones um so you
know so at that point I can do any I can
work you know I can do a lot I can read
books I can play games I can you know I
can listen to music I can do a variety
of things and it all works when I'm when
I'm disconnected and when I am on the
airplane and I can do all of that on my
Android application with my Chromebook
as well so that's very good for
Chromebooks but that's also really
consistent from a user point of view the
other thing is the way we have brought
the Android applications or the Google
Play Store to Chromebook is that it is a
native implementation and it supports a
wide set of Android api's so from a user
perspective you're going to get good
performance and you're going to get a
consistent consistent UI experience so
again like we try to just go after the
design in a way that it's a great
experience for people who are who are
used to being productive on the chrome
devices but also for the people for for
the users who are used to using Android
applications on the Google Play Store
they also see them get up get a very
positive and a really good and
consistent experience so in terms of
what kind of applications are available
almost all Android applications are
eligible for Chrome devices
some exceptions are going to be
applications which requires special
sensors so if your application requires
a GPS and a Chromebook does not have GPS
we'll filter that out in terms of how
users are going to access so the
application so remember I said
Chromebooks are very shareable which
means any user can sign into any Chrome
device and they get that same consistent
experience so the Android applications
are also tied to a user account which
means that you know any Chromebook if I
go from you know this Chromebook to this
Chromebook it will download my Android
applications and I'll be able to use
them and for those who have purchased
Android applications on another device
the same purchase application is going
to work on your Chrome devices a little
bit more details about the app
management part and how the Chrome
device management experiences so it's
centralized application management so as
an as an administrator you're going to
approve all Android applications that
can be used in your managed environment
for your manage Chromebooks so it's a
central opt-in model you approve all of
them and then in terms of curating the
applications for the users it can be
done in two different ways you can say
that your users can you allow your users
to install applications which means that
your users choice if they want they can
install that application or you can push
the applications to the users so it's
default on their device when they open
up their device and when they log in and
so again like as an administrator you
have full control and you should be able
to manage all of your Android
applications in a way that is very
consistent and it's also flexible and
the unit is at the öyou level which
means however you have set up your user
groups is going to work in terms of
managing your Android application so if
you are a business if you have multiple
locations different functions you want
to set up Android applications in
different ways for these user groups
then you can do that using the chrome
administrative capabilities
so one of my colleagues gave a talk
yesterday and as part of that she she
announced that Android kiosks apps are
also coming to Chrome OS it will come
with the Chrome OS 57 release which is
literally in a few days which means that
on your kiosk on if you're using Chrome
as a kiosk device which means you're
running a single application in an
immersive mode you will be able to also
run Android apps there and some of the
examples of Android apps one of the
example is I think Hyatt has a room
control app so you know so that's a
kiosk app which will which can run on
your device so you could set up a Chrome
device if you have an equivalent app in
your hotel room and you could just use
the same Android application another one
which which is being mentioned this
crowd DJ which is for managing
nightclubs so for those who who are in
that business so so so again like you
know we wanted to make sure that Android
apps are supported for all form factors
and all use cases so we have that for
the general user use case but also for
the kiosk use cases so I'm going to
switch gears a little bit I'm going to
talk to you about Android about the new
Chromebooks which have been designed
with Google Play in mind so as as as I
said before we continue to work with the
OEM partners and we pretty much worked
with them continuously to evolve the
range of Chromebooks and as part of the
Google Play Store coming to Chromebooks
we wanted to make sure that we had the
right devices or we were you know we we
were working on devices which can really
delight the users in terms of the
Android application experience so the at
CES this year along with Samsung we
announced Samsung Chromebook pro and
Samsung Chromebook plus so these are
devices and I have one of these here and
we do have by the way a few other
devices if you have time later to take a
look at it so this is the this is the
Samsung Chromebook plus so it's a
convertible so you can use it you can
use it as a notebook the screen and you
can come check it out later it's a
beautiful quad HD screen this actually
has a built-in panel so you can you know
so it is a built in pen which you can
take out so now you are able to write on
these devices as well
the other design choice which we made is
it's actually a three is to two screen
what this means is that the screen is
squarer but that means you can use it
well as a tablet in any orientation so
you know so those are some of the so
those are some of the optimizations are
on the hardware and it's it's pretty
thin and light so you can come and check
it out this comes with the Google Play
Store right out of the box which means
that you get Android applications and
you can do more things with this device
as soon as you get it to your house or
to your business and of course it has
all of the goodness of the Chrome
operating system so it has the speed
security simplicity shareability and
then now a lot more offline capabilities
with the Android applications so in
terms of Chromebook pro and Plus which
are the two devices which were announced
Chromebook plus was the one I showed you
it's already in market and Chromebook
plus it's powered by an arm op1
processor Chromebook pro will be coming
to market in April it's going to be
actually it's going to be a black color
device it's very professional looking
and then also it's going to have the
Intel Core m3 processor so it's been
market in April you know but pluses in
pluses in market right now so I also
wanted to point out that we have been
working with the OEM partners to build
rugged devices mainly for education use
so Acer Asus HP all of them announced
devices recently for rugged devices
which are convertibles and which have
stylus support for these are chrome
devices and again I have some of these I
have a couple of them here so you can
see again you can check them out later
this is the Acer device and you can see
it's pretty rugged this is the HP device
and this is also a rugged device so we
expect schools to start using these
devices we are seeing a lot of good
interest and then again these are
convertible and they come with pen so
you know so in terms of the pen
technology we have you can see if the
Samsung device had been built in these
are a couple of like pens and again if
your school you can you know use
different types of pens the pen
technology which we are using is EMR
which means that the pen itself is very
affordable it's not an app you know it's
not an active man you don't need to
charge it so which is which we think
should be really positive and while this
is mainly designed for education we are
hearing some interesting use case from
businesses as well so one of the use
case which we are hearing is for for
back rooms or for like retailers for
people who want to do the inventory
management they are interested in
devices like this because they also have
one interesting new feature which we
didn't have on Chromebooks before they
actually have a second camera which is
on the C panel which means that you
could use these devices so you notice if
I'm I could just go with them and
there's a camera over here so I could
take photos of storerooms and I could I
could record that so so we're starting
to diversify the range of devices
obviously these are the first set of
devices which have come in again
depending on your application we are
trying to go more into you know you can
use it as a tablet you can use it as a
PC you can have different forms of input
you can touch you can write you can
obviously type on it and you know and so
so those are and then we'll continue to
do all in the future so with that yeah
with that I'm going to invite my
colleague Shahir and Scheid is going to
come and talk to you about Android apps
and give you some demos
okay thanks Mita so many shared I'm a
product manager on Chrome OS I have a
rather selfish question actually to
begin with so those of you who have used
Chromebooks and in the past or are using
Chromebooks do you raise your hand
that's so good that anyone had you have
like Chromebooks in the room I spot a
few here and there if you have one could
you hold it up okay thank you thank you
very much for using Chromebooks we're
very excited and what all of us on the
team who work on this stuff is super
excited when we see stuff being used by
folk like you so thanks for that
okay so so we're gonna talk a little bit
about a little bit more about Android
apps so Android apps coming on to Chrome
OS
first of all let's start with
Chromebooks Chromebooks as you know
already have this best-in-class web
experience they came with chrome baked
in from the very beginning Chrome now
the most popular browser in the world
and bringing the Google Play Store on to
Chrome OS has let our users do a little
bit more so from design the team
communications it's a simple but
critical tasks like note-taking so now
you can use those apps as part of your
desktop workflow so rather than having
to pull out a phone and refer to
something on there and have multiple
devices you can just alt-tab between
apps which you're used to seeing on
mobile now on desktop so integrating it
part into the same workflow that you
already used to and in fact we've been
already working with a ton of key
developers to ensure that the apps that
you you're starting to see on Chrome OS
are optimized for Chrome OS so some of
those are internal teams but many of
them are external and we're finding that
as we talk to more and more external
teams that they're really excited about
extending out their products their
existing code bases into the desktop
environment now of course that
environments a little bit different to
mobile on mobile you have a screen
that's this big and the primary mode of
interaction it's touch but on the
desktop the screen is this big and the
primary mode of interaction is keyboard
and touchpad or Mouse now that that
means that the type of work that you're
going to be doing with that app can be
different the amount of information that
comes to you on a screen that big can be
a lot denser the the speed of input
where the keyboard can be a lot faster
than it is with touch and the accuracy
of your pointing with the touchpad can
be much better too so that means that
the the types of activities you can do
in those apps on desktop can be
different so that's so that's one aspect
but also the business models can be
different too so the really simplistic
example is on mobile it's very usual to
sell an app for one two dollars at a
time and having price points higher than
that is
is unusual it's it's it's it's it's
unusual so on desktop however a price
point of two to three hundred dollars
for example that's pretty normal
so that different type of revenue model
for the app and that different type of
interaction modes for the app has
brought us into a really exciting new
era for Android apps so that's great for
developers and it's also great for users
who are starting to see the Google Play
Store already coming into multiple
Chromebooks along with the millions of
apps that that brings so rather than
just talk about this we're going to show
you the apps in action so if we could
just switch to the the chromecast please
okay can we switch over to the
chromecast view that'd be great
okay I mean see if okay I mean to recast
okay should be good okay perfect thank
you okay so here we have an example
developer that we've been working very
closely with slack so what I'm sitting
in a room with colleague and my
colleague is reminding me that I need to
dress a little bit differently today
so I usually wear hoodies but today
stressed up a little bit since we're an
enterprise conference and I can reply
back and say thanks okay
okay and that's an example of like an
interaction that we take for granted on
desktop I can type a message and hit
enter and it sends a message back now on
mobile that's a really unusual
interaction because there's often no
keyboard attached those mobile devices
and so that's an example of the kind of
thing that an app developer will need to
keep an eye out for when we move on to
desktop and my colleague louise will
talk a little bit about that shortly but
in this case I can hit enter and rather
than doing a carriage return
it'll just send the message so if we
could switch to the camera please
thanks so now I'm going to show you
another utility so as well as these
kinds of apps that you used to like
slack all of the utility apps that
you're used to on on mobile are also
coming to Android so as Smita mentioned
earlier this device the Samsung
Chromebook plus has a stylus built into
it and as I eject it you'll see there's
a menu that pops up on screen that shows
me some options for the stylus so if we
could switch back to the chromecast
please great thanks
so this menu has just some quick tools
in like for example a laser pointer mode
so I can highlight things for
presentations like we're doing right now
but I'm just going to turn that off
so I'm going to switch to another app
that we've been working with closely
Evernote so I'm going to convert this
device from a the laptop form factor
into the tablet form factor so I can do
things like handwriting much more easily
so that's exactly what we're going to do
so I'm going to add a new handwriting
note so imagine I'm in a meeting and I
just need to take a few quick notes so
I'm gonna take notes for next ok and
we're gonna have a blazer and shoes not
trainers which is what I usually wear
because I'm doing this digitally I can
do selects reposition things to be where
I want erase restore etc all of those
kinds of functions so that's great
but now because I'm on a convertible
device the Samsung Chromebook I can
switch out to to see this same note and
it's going to head back into it here ok
and I can actually add just typed notes
on to this if I want to because my
handwriting as you can see is pretty
atrocious if I have a couple of minutes
after this meeting I can just convert
these notes into typed text and then
send them out to my colleagues
afterwards something they can actually
read so that's just a couple of the the
apps that we wanted to show you that we
have live here now if we just head back
to the slides please thanks but we also
wanted to showcase a few other apps very
briefly so these Android apps aren't
just about google apps third-party apps
like you've seen and one of the key
non-google apps that we've had requests
for is Skype and Skype for business so
that's already available on the Play
Store and you can go and install that
and use it and the same as you would on
your mobile devices Evernote which syncs
across devices so you can start exactly
where you left off so as in this case I
can now pull up my phone which is
already logged into the same account and
add on to that same note or start a new
one and that'll be synchronized across
all of these devices slack for efficient
team communication and rich
notifications so inside that app if I
get a get more messages from my
colleagues about a for a chatroom all
right I'm in that rich notification will
pop up in the same way that it would as
if I was on a mobile device a ton of
Google Apps like for example Google
Calendar and the advantage here is that
they work offline so you can check into
and read all of that data in the same
way you would as if you're you're on
mobile and for those of you in the
education space and just a quick show of
hands who here is okay fantastic thank
you so for those of you play brings a
host of Education apps to Chrome OS
those apps are easy to manage in the
same way that for those of you have
Chromebook deployments in education
you're already used to so admins can
push those Android apps to compatible
devices just very simply through the
chrome management console it
genuinely very easy have kunis at the
end if that's okay but thanks
and it's true sort of turnkey app
deployment the other thing we wanted to
just call out is that adobe recently
announced with us at the BET conference
that there's a forthcoming release of
updated adobe android apps that are
optimized for Chrome OS specifically for
education that will help students
harness their creativity and develop key
creative skills that they can use as
they progress through their career so
that's a little bit about some of the
apps that already exist but now I'd like
to turn over to my colleague Luiz he's
gonna tell you a little bit more how you
can optimize your apps it's actually
hidden so my name is receptor Chavis I
am one of the engineers in the team that
made it possible to run Android
applications on Chrome OS so this
section of the talk is actually aimed
the app developers in the room which I
think it just won and it's about the
best practices so you can provide a much
better ended experience on Chromebooks
so first of all we are running a fully
CTS and GTS compiled compliant Android
system on Chrome OS this means that most
applications can run in Chrome OS
without any modifications in your park
there's absolutely no code changes
required but as mentioned earlier most
Android applications are optimized for
touch and a very different physical form
factor and device model so you may still
want to optimize your application so it
runs even better on Chromebooks um there
is a very wide variety of Chromebook
form factors most of them will have a
physical keyboard in the trackpad some
of them will support touching the screen
and others will support alternative
input mechanisms like the stylus way we
showed earlier well we're testing
applications a lot of them were already
working great with all the simple
mechanisms still not all of these
applications did so you need to make
sure that you can fall back gracefully
whenever users are interacting with your
app using a keyboard a touchpad or or
even a physical mouse instead of touch
or stylus
one other thing you can consider is that
given that most Chromebooks will have a
physical keyboard productivity
applications can become even more
productive by adding some features like
hard key support in general
Chromebooks support less amount of
sensors than mobile devices for instance
most Android developers are used to
having a physical GPS sensor other under
devices Chromebooks are not equipped
with one but you can still get a course
location information thanks to the use
of Wi-Fi which we're okay for more
situations Ramos also have partial
support for other sensors like
accelerometer and gyroscopes for an
exhaustive list of which sensors we do
support on Chromebooks and the
capabilities in which we support them
please visit developer that Android the
comm for the poor list
another thing that differentiates
Chromebooks from other Android devices
is the screen is much larger and winder
in in its default orientation you will
have a lot more screen real estate
available now so it's better if you make
the best use of it as possible make sure
your application can leverage the full
width of the device instead of
constraining yourself to a narrow strip
of content in the middle like we see in
the picture here one of the top sources
of unexpected behavior of Android apps
on Chromebooks is due to the screen
being a lot larger than expected so
please make sure to take this into
account when developing your app using
backup and restore effectively so so
very important as my colleagues I
mentioned earlier one of the best
features about Chromebooks is that users
can just grab any machine from a pool of
shared devices login to that Chromebook
and all their applications will be there
having said that we as Chrome OS don't
support synchronizing the apps data
that's something us app developers need
to do in order to do that please make
sure you use androids default backup and
restore a pice that'll make your users
way more happy and productive
one caveat is that local storage and the
devices is not infinite
so if too many users log into one device
at some point we'll need to evict some
of the older accounts together with the
or local storage so please take this
into account Chromebooks are currently
shipping with marshmallow api's but you
need to make sure to plan to move to new
get as soon as possible today if it's a
if it's a possibility since several
things will improve as soon as you move
to new yet and we will be shipping new
at later this year as well for
Chromebooks the most important thing is
that if you add support for it your
applications will be able to resize
arbitrarily instead of being constrained
to just one or two orientations you'll
be able to make your applications feel
more natural with the rest of the
operating system although other API
you'll be able to leverage by switching
to new get are a drag and drop across
applications and mouse cursor api's this
will improve the desktop experience
significantly so by being ready for new
yet you make sure your application will
leverage this API so as soon as we
convert the Chromebooks and with that
back to Smith
thanks Louisa and chai head so this
wraps up our presentation so some of the
things we went over we talked to you a
little bit about the Chrome operating
system chrome devices for work some of
the design approaches we took devices
designed for for Google Playstore we
talked about Android apps demos some
showcase and tips for optimizing so
these are some of the resources which
are available for you if you to explore
more optimizing apps for Chromebooks
Chromebooks with Android applications so
this this tells which chrome devices
will be getting the Android applications
we are the Google Play Store which ones
already have it and then also articles
on how do you manage Android
applications and Chromebooks if you
search this is pretty pretty much be the
top articles which are going to pop up
so you know so feel free to do it to
look for these and get more information
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you